all right well as we wrap up here i'd
love your predictions for the election
who wins and what's this going to look
like if there's a kind of dispute
over who wins i think that if the
election were held fairly
i would guess with i don't know call it
60
certainty that trump wins i think uh is
as you see even
as the polls show biden up nationally
let's not forget by the way they're
saying biden's up 14 points nationally
somewhere between 9 and 14 points
uh october same time in 2016 they said
hillary clinton was up by the exact same
amount nationally 14 points
obviously didn't work out for her so you
see biden up nationally in the polls but
in the swing states you see president
trump is surging so all the momentum in
the states that are actually going to
decide the election
is going for trump and i think probably
that is going to continue
as biden and harris get a greater
examination or a slight examination even
by the mainstream media so i think if
the election world fairly trump
probably wins it you know i'd put a
little bit of money on it however
we're already in a constitutional crisis
they're expecting 80 to 100 million
mail-in votes we've never had a system
of unsolicited mail
funds you know there's a line of fact
check going around
michael there's never been a problem
with mail-in votes before we've had mail
and votes for a long time
that cannot be true because we have
never had a system of widespread
unsolicited mail-in votes so there
is no precedent there is nothing to look
back on we do know that there is voter
fraud in mail-in
and we do know that this system is more
susceptible to voter fraud so it's
obviously going to be litigated
biden has already hired 600 lawyers to
to deal with this they are
they're already telling us on the left
there won't be a result on election
night
they're saying actually on election
night it will look like trump has won
but it will be a red mirage
and uh after they i don't know they pick
up a bunch of votes of dead people in
illinois and ohio or something
then they're they're going to see that
joe biden has won the election
hillary clinton has said joe biden
should not not uh concede the election
under any circumstances oh my goodness
yes including president trump winning
right i mean that is a radical statement
so it is going to be litigated i think
you're probably going to see a bush v
gore situation
i wasn't i wasn't here during that time
but i am interested in seeing what
happens just within this country of
yours
see how i put that distance between me
and your country just because i'm afraid
the whole thing's going to burn down and
i need an escape route
like it is pretty freaking desperate
isn't it like i know that we can say
that the news magnifies things and it's
really not that bad everywhere but
like it's i'm looking around like it's
pretty bad right
like is this normal sh nikes well matt
if it makes you feel better it's going
to get worse it's going to get a lot
worse and
i think you're i think very likely
you're going to get a kind of bush v
gore situation but bush figure was one
state
i mean that was that we're just talking
about florida here you're going to see i
don't know it could be
three or five states it could be more
than that even and so presumably this
will be litigated up to the supreme
court
they're going to call the court decision
illegitimate because judge barrett
replaced ruth ginsburg
we are headed i'm sorry to predict for
chaos